ねえ、聞いて
今日、大きなニュースがあったんだ
2026年の1月に
政府が発表したのは
再生可能エネルギーの目標
2030年までに40%へ
太陽の光と風の力で
電気を作っていくんだって
30%から10%も増やすって
大きな決断だよね
今までとは違う道を
選んだってことなのかな
脱炭素社会への
大きな一歩かもしれない
地球のことを考えて
未来を守るために
変わろうとしてるんだね
電気代は上がるかもしれない
でも未来は明るくなるかもしれない
新しい仕事も増えるかもしれない
あたしたちの未来が変わるかもしれない
簡単じゃないかもしれないけど
きっと、意味があるはずだから
一緒に見守っていこうよ
この変化を
送電網を整えたり
色んな準備が必要で
すぐには変わらないかもしれない
でも、一歩ずつ進んでる
専門家の人たちは言うの
長い目で見れば安定するって
確かに時間はかかるけど
未来のための選択なんだ
今までとは違う道を
選んだってことなのかな
脱炭素社会への
大きな一歩かもしれない
地球のことを考えて
未来を守るために
変わろうとしてるんだね
電気代は上がるかもしれない
でも未来は明るくなるかもしれない
新しい仕事も増えるかもしれない
あたしたちの未来が変わるかもしれない
簡単じゃないかもしれないけど
きっと、意味があるはずだから
一緒に見守っていこうよ
この変化を
あたしたちにできることって
何だろうね
節電することも
学ぶことも
小さなことかもしれないけど
きっと意味があるよね
一緒に、未来を作ろう
電気代は上がるかもしれない
でも未来は明るくなるかもしれない
新しい仕事も増えるかもしれない
あたしたちの未来が変わるかもしれない
簡単じゃないかもしれないけど
きっと、意味があるはずだから
一緒に見守っていこうよ
この変化を
一緒に、未来を作ろう